quoi parce que c'est là qu'ils parlent
maintenant de statuer peut accepter le
statut neutre de legrand et c'est
l'intérêt national ukrainien parce que
l'international ukrainien s'est pas du
tout d'être fer de lance de la politique
comme l'a dit martine peut se contenter
de ça je mets des guillemets à contenter
principal je m'excuse son exigence sonné
que les gens en fonction sur les
provinces mais attendez les exigences
exigence principale c'est sur l'exigence
principale c'était que le cren il dit sa
formule ne soit pas un ti russie entier
russie c'est à dire fer de lance contre
le contre contre la russie mais je vous
dis comme craignant de mettre la main
sur le crâne
je vais vous dire vous parle il ya des
gens notamment les américains me disent
encore hier et m'ont dit 'nous voulons
nouveau gagner ce temps là bas nous
voulons il ya un bassin d'eau français
sur avec moi sur le plateau qui a dit
nous allons nous battre à kiev jusqu'aux
derniers craignant vous savez j'étais
gêné par sa le temps il va battre se
battre accueillir jusqu'au dernier en
craignant parce que vous savez c'est
l'émoi attendait ses morceaux créés n'ya
que je vous dis il y à cette possibilité
et je pense et j'appuie je sais que les
américains veulent transformer ce
conflit une sorte de prélude de la chute
de la russie et de beauty c'est c'est
aussi en danger pour moi parce que vous
comprenez si la logique est vrai si on
pousse la russie dos au mur avec
beaucoup de morts et cetera et cetera
dans ce cas là c'est ça peut être
beaucoup plus dangereux que vous le
pensez parce que ces gens là ils peuvent
dans ce cas-là aller dans la détresse
jusqu'à l'autorisation vraiment ne
désarme extrême pourquoi
il faut qu'on je voudrais pas entrer
dans le détail parce que c'est beaucoup
plus il faut voir très clair parce qu'il
ya autour de ça il vous faut faire
attention parce qu'il ya la guerre donne
des suppositions et de la propagande
mais en revanche guère une couleur c'est
tout à fait possible c'est banaliser et
dans ce cas là vous comprenez il a dit
encore une fois l'autre jour poutine il
a dit le monde sans la russie ne
m'intéresse pas quand je raconte dans le
livre je donne des clés pour déchiffrer
le personnage vous comprenez je donne
trois clés je tourne la clé quand il est
enfant abandonné et je pense qu'il a
créée principal de sa psychologie il
était formé par la pègre et dans la
réalité c'est quelqu'un qui est jusqu'au
boutiste dans la crise aujourd'hui les
jusqu'au boutistes
il ne recule pas il dit qu'en ce matin
est inévitable quand il était enfant et
là il était imprégné de cette culture il
se lance dans la bataille et il va
jusqu'au bout l'enfant formé par la
pègre ça c'est la première clé deuxième
clé c'est la clé
comment vous dire de presque sportive
c'est un grand judoka et l'utilisent
les gens au fait les adversaires sont la
force de l'adversaire pour remporter les
victoires et bien sûr il est aussi un
joueur d'échecs comme tous les russes
mais au delà de ça c'est surtout l'homme
de renseignement c'est une sorte de
héros prend pour james bond russo
comprends ça c'est les choses comme ça
et il utilise la technique du
renseignement sur ce plan là les
rapports de force mais quand il dit que
les rues 600 le monde sans la russie ne
m'intéresse pas il faut qu'il faut comme
je pense qu'il reflète le fond de sa
pensée et ça c'est ça m'effraie vous
comprenez ça veut dire qu'on est on est
possible mais ça veut dire qu'il est
prêt à aller jusqu'au bout voilà
jusqu'au bout jusqu'au bout c'est à dire
si si mais il l'a dit hier en temps
jusqu'au bout
malgré
la guerre nucléaire et quand il parle
qu'est ce que ça veut dire l'intérêt
mais vous comprenez la banalisation de
la guerre nucléaire c'est ce que les
américains se trame sur les autres je
suis effrayé par ça déchire et je ne
dors pas la nuit d'où mon soutien
passionné
de la démarche française
[Musique]